- [Voiceover] Karunesh is a
gym owner who wants to offer
a full schedule of yoga and
circuit training classes.
Yoga classes are each one
and a half hours long,
while circuit training
classes are only an hour,
and he wants at least 25 hours of classes,
at least 25 hours of classes,
on the schedule each week.
All of his instructors
are paid $35 per class,
so it doesn't matter whether it's
an hour and a half yoga class,
or a one hour circuit training class.
But Karunesh doesn't want
to spend more than $1000,
does not want to spend more than $1000
per week on salaries.
Which of the following falls within
Karunesh's guidelines
for the weekly schedule?
So we can just go through
these choices and we can say,
which of these meet the at
least 25 hours of classes,
but then don't break the bank,
don't cost more than $1000.
So this first one right over here is
three yoga classes, at
an hour and a half each,
well this is going to be
four point five hours here,
plus 19 hours,
each circuit training class is an hour,
so plus 19 hours,
is going to get you to
23 and a half hours.
So that doesn't get us
to at least 25 hours
of classes, so we can rule that out.
I'll see ten yoga classes and
12 circuit training classes.
Ten yoga classes at an
hour and a half each
is going to be 15 hours,
plus the 12 circuit training classes,
that does get us to 27 hours.
So it checks off the
minimum number of hours
that he wants to get,
now let's make sure it
doesn't break the bank.
So the classes are $35 per class
regardless of whether its an
hour and a half yoga class,
or it's a one hour circuit training class.
So right over here
we're gonna have a total of ten plus 12,
so this is going to be 22 classes,
22 classes times $35 per class.
And what is this going to be?
Look, I can already tell
it's going to be less
than a thousand, and if you
were under time pressure
you could say, Hey, this
is less than a thousand.
But if you want to verify
that this right over here
is less than a thousand,
two times 35 is 70.
And then two times, sorry,
and then 20 times 35 is 700.
700, so that's going to be $770.
I know I did this in a
somewhat non-traditional way,
I could have done it like this,
35 times 22,
so two times 35 is 70,
20 times 35 is 700,
you add them together,
you get 770.
But the important point is
this is less than $1000.
So this is going to meet our constraints.
We have enough hours
but we haven't broken the bank.
Now in these two,
it looks like we have
plenty of hours here,
in fact, just the yoga class is enough
to meet our 25 hours
because 20 yoga classes
is going to be 30 hours of classes,
and 25's gonna be even more.
But I would suspect that these
are gonna break the bank.
And if you look at this,
this is gonna be 32 classes
at 35 dollars per class,
yeah, that's going to be over $1000.
And this one, I said this was even,
this was going to be 31 classes,
and so this is probably going to be
over $1000, as well.